In the year 2000,
when Putin had just come to power,
he asked Bill Clinton to let Russia join NATO. Yes,
Putin wanted to join NATO,
but Clinton told him something
that pissed him off so much
that Putin made it his life's mission to destroy NATO.
Here is what happened
when Putin had just become the president. He said,
Russia is part of the European culture,
and I cannot imagine my own country
in isolation from Europe.
NATO countries were weak and highly
dependent on the United States for their security.
But Russia joining NATO
would have challenged United States authority
and would have made it ineffective,
since the US would have to consult Russia.
That's when Putin realized
that NATO is just the US's tool to project power
and not an alliance where Russia is welcomed.